if you're looking to escape the heat
we're talking about the heat yeah ellis
island is now offering a new tropical
hideaway
and i stopped by earlier today for an
exclusive first look
welcome to las vegas newest hidden tiki
pop-up bar welcome
to the island at alice and this place is
so cool i'm in love with it
christina thank you for having us how
are you thanks for coming okay
why why create a hidden tiki pop-up bar
why not i mean who doesn't love a tiki
bar for summer
we've had so much fun decorating the
front yard during all the different
holidays
so that says summer more like a tiki bar
can you show us around because
this place really is so cool yes come on
all right first off lance get a shot
[ __ ] right here because you have
do you have the hockey games on here at
the bar of course he has tons of tiki
nights
so games on all week long we have our
little lounge area
and then we new addition to us have
blackjack up here now for the first time
ever okay
so people come up here just kind of hang
out with some friends because all
restrictions are lifted
yes all restrictions are lifted you can
come hang out in our lounge order drinks
and food off the bar we have tiki drinks
and then tiki bites
okay let's go back to this you were
talking about this is really cool this
is the premiere because it opens
tomorrow it's a pop-up bar
opens tomorrow and goes to july 4th till
july 4th yes i love the uh the custom
the island at ellis uh the custom
blackjack tables and what a cool view of
looking out onto the yard and also you
see the strip from here as well
yes blackjack with a view and tiki
drinks what could be better
nothing this is absolutely perfect for
the summer too it has that island vibe
let's go to the bar because it is a
tikki bar is right
absolutely yes so here we have for you
to try
our mermaids hangover do you know what's
in a mermaid hangover yes it's spiced
bacardi
tropical fruit and then some other
secret ingredients all right
wow that's delicious awesome that's real
good okay
what's that one over there this one we
have our
oh there goes the garnish our painkiller
you know a drink is good when it's
called the painkiller
absolutely uh this is what the colorado
avalanche is going to need tonight the
pain killer after the knights take it to
him right here we go
that's so good that's another going
awesome yeah we also on the menu a
classic
mai tai and then some other spins on
mojitos and other tiki drinks
people watching right now i mean it's
only to be here for a month i'm thinking
maybe keep it all summer i'm just saying
it's a really cool vibe here if
someone's watching do they can they
reserve a spot here at the bar or in the
lounge
absolutely go to our website ellis
islandcasino.com and you can make a
reservation
make sure you select island at ella so
you can select your seat up here versus
downstairs perfect thank you christina
we'll have more coming up in the four
o'clock hour send it back to you guys in
the studio
that was a pretty big gulp it was the
cocktail was kicked
in i forgot i had to come back here i'm
like i'll send it back to you guys in
the studio i'm going to hang out here
all afternoon
it is so cool that reservations are not
required but you can reserve a spot
at elliseislandcasino.com it's so neat
down there that was
great all right